lui c'est julien début mai à paris loin
de ses habitudes de ses employés mais il
n'est pas seul il a toute sa cuisine
dans la tête et ça paye cette année
monsieur médard julien le vainqueur du
concours du panier mystère c'est lui le
revoilà julien chez lui dans son élément
cette fois on va partir sur une truite
sur le corps avec une mousseline de
carotte un peu de curcuma est
directement ici c'est lui le chef
mais il ya quelques jours au concours il
avait rien à dire trois ingrédients
imposés dans l'assiette
c'était du beau duo marc et du foie gras
tous les mêmes règles et voilà il n'ya
pas de préparation en amont avec un
meilleur ouvrier de france où on arrive
on est tous pareils
c'est vraiment la technicité du
cuisinier et l'inspiration loin d'être
facile le panier mystère du goût de la
texture bref de la grande cuisine savait
qu'il fallait pas laisser les choses au
hasard
non seulement les cuissons ils attendent
de la technicité et surtout du respect
du produit un filet mignon de veau trop
cuisse et je pense disqualifier un
homard trop sec ou pas assez cuit s'est
disqualifiée voilà j'ai tout misé sur la
précision des cuissons
au menu dans son restaurant des produits
simples qu'il passionne il les
transforme les fait briller il est
marient entre eux un principe déjà de
couleur mettra frambois ça se ressemble
donc on met ensemble et pour l'apéritif
c'est ce qu'il faut il faut démarrer sur
des acidités de façon à ouvrir les
palais les papilles sont là et après la
sont prêtes à déguster des inspirations
aussi multiples le terroir français les
produits japonais et jean françois piège
le modèle mais dans l'assiette pour le
client c'est bien julien et personne
d'autre pour que quand il a mangé
quelque chose qui se disent qu'il n'a
jamais mangé quelque part et qui se dit
que la première fois c'était ici donc on
essaye d'être un peu un peu précurseur
de ça même si on en a vendu rien
aujourd'hui mais on essaye quand même de
deux marqués par par les sentiments
comme nous dans la cuisine le panier
mystère défi relevé haut la main et puis
maintenant le rêve ultime du cuistot la
suite logique
ils y pensent vraiment à sa première
étoile